at quaint Center and he is the cohort
neither of this event and instead of
talking about regulatory incentives
towards to centralization let's move the
speaker I love them
so hopefully this will be a fun one I
sort of decided to go for it with
strange metaphors and old history of
philosophy of law and things like that
but it should still stay relevant I
think and then the other disclaimer I
was gonna make is a lot of this will be
semi US focused and I actually think
there's probably a majority of non-us
people in the room which is awesome
right now but the concepts that I'm
discussing from a regulatory standpoint
easily apply more broadly to securities
laws anti money laundering laws that
exist in almost every country around the
world in a fairly similar form
so with that disclosure I wanted to
start with this awesome illustration
dude does anyone recognize it this is
yeah so this is the front piece from
Hobbes's Leviathan it was drawn by a
French illustrator I believe for the
publication of Hobbes's treatise on
basically justifying the the power of
the state and and what's cool about it
is it's made out of people like Soylent
Green there's just lots of little people
and they're all facing inward to form
some sort of civil Association and Hubbs
use this sort of vaguely contract like
theory to justify the power of the state
of course so it's it's a it's a cool
image I don't have too much to say about
it other than that it definitely raises
the topic of decentralisation that a
sovereign is is itself of a body of
individuals and will have more to say
about Hobbes in a second so what do I
mean by regulatory incentives towards
decentralization when you hear someone
in the economics literature the legal
literature you usually talk about
incentives from government
usually thinking of things like
subsidies like an actual payment from
the government to some person or group
of persons that's engaging in an
activity that the government would like
to see more of because it's socially
beneficial or maybe because governments
corrupt and wants to support some
private interests so it pays them and so
these can be good or bad but government
gives money in the US for example to the
Space Launch System which is this
attempt to build a replacement for the
space shuttle out of the same parts the
Space Shuttle was made out of this is
how the SLS is I mean there's innovation
going on in SLS too I see someone like
like thinking I don't mean to impugn the
SLS too much but there's definitely an
interesting reason why maybe the
government would want to hand money to
the SLS project rather than SpaceX like
Elon Musk startup it's because
congressmen have several Congress people
have the factories in their districts
that made the old Space Shuttle parts
and the idea that those factories are
gonna close because we're not using the
Space Shuttle anymore is frustrating so
you know it's the subsidy is it good is
it bad it might be bad of course you can
get subsidized by the government to buy
a Tesla a really fancy luxury car with
these like cool doors but you know maybe
this is good because it's stimulating
innovation into battery technology that
will ultimately mean that one day
everyone can afford a Tesla and then we
won't have gas guzzling vehicles and we
might do some you know positive things
with respect to climate change maybe
seems desperate at this point but you
know me and then this is a personal
example from Washington DC where I'm
from cuz I got to be where the
regulator's are that's what coin Center
does is we educate regulators about the
technology this is the DC streetcar has
anyone ridden on the DC streetcar yeah
even if I said that in DC everyone would
shake their head because the bus is
faster and this thing it often breaks
down but because it's on Rails they
can't move it and then it blocks traffic
on H Street because it's a streetcar in
traffic and this is all new stuff like
San Francisco's have streetcars forever
and they actually work pretty well in DC
we were like oh hipster
like streetcars maybe it'll bring like
gentrification to this neighborhood I
don't think they said it like that but
you know that was the implication it was
a lot of real estate developers who
pushed for this because it's charming
and stupid so that's a bad that that's
definitely I think that's not
contentiously a bad subsidy but this was
all just my hopefully vaguely amusing
comedy routine on subsidies the question
should we give people in our space
subsidies I think no I think probably
not maybe we can have a conversation
about that but that's not what this talk
about is about anyway I'm talking about
regulatory incentives not in the form of
subsidies but a lack or an absence of
regulatory taxes and my argument is that
in the u.s. at least and increasingly in
the rest of the world we actually have a
very good regime with respect to crypto
currencies and open blockchain networks
that abstains from taxing through
regulation those networks which makes
them more competitive than they
otherwise would be as compared to the
legacy financial services that they're
replacing whether it's things like the
traditional banks and things like that
is a subsidy I am a lawyer Joe but put
yeah please I'm sorry say one more time
if you aren't taxing as a matter of
policy because you want this tech to get
off the ground that is yeah I agree
I think the inverse is also true just of
simple yeah yeah so what I really mean
is these are regulatory taxes if you
issue a security in the United States
you're gonna spend money on your s1 or
maybe I'm finding a lawyer to explain
why you can get an exemption from filing
a normal disclosure it's going to be a
very expensive process and those costs
are effectively attacks on people who
would want to otherwise issue security
another example if you want to do money
transmission in the United States you're
gonna have to spend lots of money on any
anti money laundering program and get
licenses in the 53 states and
territories that require licenses for
that activity that's a very expensive
regulatory tax that we have in the US
and so what I'm saying is maybe if you
provide a similar service as regulated
entities but don't meet the statutory
definition of money transmission or
securities issuance then there's less
money you need to pay in compliance and
you get a regulatory incentive now the
naive view of what I just said or the
simple view of what I just said is that
that's actually kind of cynical because
this looks like we're just finding a
clever way around the statutory
definition through rhetoric or chicanery
is the term we use in the law to argue
that you know well this isn't that
because it's got a token associated with
it or this isn't that because it's got
blockchain or this isn't that because in
Angela's words yesterday this isn't an
intermediary this is some other thing in
the middle it's not an intermediary and
that sounds like bad faith and I don't
intend to suggest actually that we're
getting these incentives in bad faith I
think we're actually getting these
incentives for the right reasons
and part of our job at coin Center is to
explain to people in government how
these technologies work and why maybe
for the right reasons they don't fit
into the existing laws at least not all
of the existing laws it's really only
cynical to say that that's a regulatory
incentive if you think that the law that
you're getting around is essentially a
bad law so it depends on how you feel
about securities laws and state
licensing and ANSI money laundering
policy if we're just like finding a way
around it because we think it's [ __ ]
to use probably the right term that
somebody who feels that would use then
it's cynical and this is you know this
is not a new crypto anapest belief
people have questioned the necessary
Nisour a long time even Thomas Hobbes
from our first slide wrote in Leviathan
unnecessary laws are not good laws but
traps for money
they're just rent-seeking they're just
trying to make the field more
complicated for people who would
otherwise want to do something so they
can extract rents from those people and
st. Augustine this is just one of my
favorite quotes said without justice
what our kingdoms but great bands of
robbers so the question is between
anti-money laundering law securities law
and state money transmission licensing
laws are any of these unnecessary in
which case they're just traps for money
or unjust in which case we should see
them as effectively a type of robbery
this is how I feel I do not think that
anti-money laundering law or securities
law as they're currently enforced in the
US are either unjust or unnecessary with
respect to state money transmission
licensing law I have mixed feelings I
think maybe these are bad laws actually
I'm not going to go into a lot of depth
about state money transmission licensing
because at some level it's a very
parochial u.s. problem and if you're
interested we have this report at this
web ad
that explains all the problems with
state money transmission licensing but
the basic intuition here is if you're
doing something with cryptocurrency
you're holding other people's bitcoins
for example you're engaging in it in a
global system let alone a system that
will be both in New York and California
so why would you choose the states as
the level of regular regulation for
licensing what it really means is if
you're a coin base for example or
cracken and you know I don't I'm more
interested in the underlying technology
I don't care too much about the
businesses built on top of it but I
don't want the businesses built on top
of it having to go through absurd hoops
just to operate so if you're any of
those exchanges you have to get licensed
in 53 different states and territories
and that's just ridiculous because the
53rd time that you submit a criminal
background check from yourself and your
board members is not going to catch the
crimes that the other 52 criminal
background checks didn't catch and
you're already going to hold the minimum
capitalization requirements of whichever
state has the largest minimum
capitalization requirements so having
another application and another
application for money transmission
licensing makes no sense should we
license exchanges to make sure they
don't lose customer funds like that I
just said BitFenix I meant mal Cox
that's an interesting yes maybe
licensing is a good way to address those
consumer protection concerns but I think
it should be done either at the state
level at the federal level which is what
we talked about in this paper or we
could do something like they do in the
European Union with emoney licenses
where you get one license in one state
and you can passport it to other member
states of the federal or the larger
polity anyway so I think I think
actually state license is going to still
currently exist in the u.s. is kind of
unjust and kind of unnecessary yes
private business around the processing
of state money licenses
they're called lawyers I do you mean you
mean the actual accepting the
applications and so there is a there is
actually a trade association called the
money transmitters regulators
Association and the State Conference of
bank supervisors there's two trade
associations of regulators and they meet
and they talk about how they make it
maybe could make the application process
more unified amongst all the states and
easier
they don't make too much progress and
you know I don't mean to be cynical
again or malicious but when your
incentives are to not make your state's
you know regulatory budget irrelevant
because in other states now doing it and
you've got a reciprocity agreement or
something you're not going to move
quickly to make yourself irrelevant and
so there there are some bad public
choice incentives that have that have
allowed this this regime to continue far
longer that it's obviously reasonable
like money transmission licensing was
originally something that you'd need if
you were opening a corner store in I
don't know San Antonio Texas where you
were gonna do like Bill pang for people
who wanted to come in with cash and then
send a wire and that's like a very local
business with a local clientele that's
vulnerable it makes sense to have a
local regulator that's not what PayPal's
like at all let alone coinbase so that
old geographic distribution of
regulatory power doesn't make sense
anymore and it really just becomes a
trap for money rather than adjust
regulation I would say yes it's a a huge
cottage industry and it shouldn't exist
if we had good regulation here if we had
a single license that did all the
protections that we would want rather
than fifty three redundant licenses
realistic chance of the federal
government actually doing this or can
the sense just they argue that they're
regulating something that the yep so so
the issue is you'd need to figure out
which regulator does this and no
regulator has a clear statutory mandate
to create a federal license as an
alternative to state licenses for money
transmission the the obvious candidates
are just the the OCC which charters
federal banks but money transmitters
aren't banks so it's not really their
legal purview just to stick their neck
out and do that and the CFTC would be a
good choice for crypto specific stuff
because we're treating these things
often like commodities now the CFTC all
right already regulates derivatives
markets for underlying for contracts
with college but commodities underlying
them it doesn't regulate spot markets
like what coin bases where it's just non
derivative trades but they'd have the
expertise to do it but they'd also need
new authority from Congress to regulate
a spot market versus a derivative market
there is a bill that will likely be
introduced soon that would actually
propose that kind of power for the CFTC
to regulate spot markets for those who
want to get out of the state money
transmission licensing system now
whether that passes I'm not so sure and
if you want there's that report that I
wrote about federal alternatives we
described a couple of different ways you
can do it anyway so we're gonna ignore
state licensing for the rest of the talk
and focus on these two big ones which
again have analogs in every country
around the world so even though I'm
talking about the SEC and the Treasury
we're talking about anti-money
laundering regulation like FATA in
Europe and and globally and we're
talking about securities regulation
which seems like more of a u.s. concern
because our securities laws appear to be
drafted in a broader sense but I think
it's not naive to believe that say the
German security regulator BAFF and
seeing the experience in the u.s.
decides to extend the the breadth of
their securities laws they're definitely
thinking about that
so a few things that I want to lay out
first as far as unnecessary and unjust
laws because just talking about those
things in the abstract is like well
that's just your opinion dude so maybe
we can develop without going too deep
into legal philosophy or economics of
law or public choice theory develop some
ideas about when laws are necessary and
when they are just or unjust so the
first concept I want to introduce is a
very old one called pigouvian tax ation
from this british economist arthur puku
he was writing back in the 1800s
at the time people were building
factories to make drastically cheaper
consumer goods but and and industrial
products but at the same time these
factories were spreading soot all over
London the moths in London actually
evolved from white moths to black moths
in order to camouflage against the soot
covered buildings there were selection
pressures and they evolved it was that
bad so pabu's thinking all right it's
clear that these factories are selling
goods and the goods have a certain price
and and yet there's also some other
hidden costs in the way industrial
production has progressed and those
costs are not being borne by either the
factory or the consumer buying the
factories goods they're being borne by
society they are socialized costs of
having soot everywhere and Pegu called
this a negative externality building off
of the earlier economic war work of
Marshall and Pegu said all right well if
we can quantify a social cost and a
negative externality from a particular
activity then we should be able to tax
that person who's creating that social
cost to the amount of the negative
externality and that will create an
incentive for them to either stop
producing the negative externality or we
can use the tax revenue to you know
amend or repair the damage that's being
done by their negative externality and
so this is a good idea I think generally
speaking this is a decent way of looking
at regulation we've got much more
advanced theories now but
actually this this formative nugget is
still key to most public choice theory
about regulation and then the other
principle I want to explain is this
principle that comes mostly from tort
law but you see it in the law and
economics literature of the least-cost
avoider I love this picture because this
picture you need only look at it and
feel like things have changed
drastically in how we entertain
ourselves this is people who decided to
spend their I don't know Saturday
afternoon watching motorcycles with side
cars with lions in them go around a
so-called wall of death which is a
circular wall that if you go fast enough
on a motorcycle you can go sideways
wells of death still exist I don't think
you can find a place where you can view
them where there isn't like a big cage
separating the viewers from the rapidly
moving motorcycles and I don't think I
mean feel free to correct me if anyone
knows otherwise I don't think you can
find lions inside cars in the walls of
death anymore that still exists within
society anyway I bring up this fanciful
thing from the past in that dangerous
situations are often addressed through
tort law which is where you know if that
step was improperly marked or a little
bit too high a little bit too low and I
trip over it and break my nose
then I sue Alessandro or Berkeley or
someone because there was negligence and
the this is not dissimilar from the
negative externality context it's like
there was some sort of hidden cost and I
suffered it and you should have been
responsible for revealing that hidden
cost now in tort law we could hold lots
of people responsible so if this guy you
know ends up the lion flies off this you
know from the centripetal force and
lands on him and and Gore's his arm but
he survives he could sue a lot of people
right and then the judge would have to
say okay who at the least-cost
could have avoided this accident done
something to avoid this accident if you
will they could say that they you know
maybe it's these guys who decided to do
this maybe it's the people actually
moving around the circle or maybe it's
the perm
who designed the wall of death and
didn't have you know bars over the top
and judges in tort law will even say
well actually maybe it's you
maybe you the guy who got gored by the
centripetal lion was the least cost
avoider because you didn't have to go to
this thing everyone knows this thing is
dangerous and you walked right up to it
and you were just like looking over and
then slide going around at 70 miles per
hour and so this is just a general
concept that it makes sense to find if
you can or at least develop a theory
because quantifying things in complex
systems is hard at least develop a
reasonable theory of who's the
least-cost avoider and then impose your
pigouvian tax on that person not on
someone who it would be too costly for
them to avoid the harm and so another
way of thinking about this that that
harkens back to our leo framing the
pigouvian tax looks for a negative
externality that's basically like saying
that we have a necessary we have a
reason for a law there's something
necessary that needs to be addressed
there is an externality and the least
cost avoid or principle says if you do
it right if you found the right person
in society to address that cost that's
more of a just law if you impose that
burden of stopping that harm on someone
who couldn't do it cheaply or easily
then it's not really a just law it's
kind of unfair like why did that guy or
girl end up responsible for amending or
stopping the harm so I think we can go
back to Hobbes and st. Augustine or we
can talk about you know Cardozo and tort
law and Pegu and taxing but this is the
framework I want to look at things in
now there's other frameworks for legal
ethics and for figuring out whether we
should regulate things there's there's
much more in the law and economics
literature than these two concepts and
then there's deontological theories of
like because I am a being with certain
you know rights behind a veil of
ignorance or any number of other things
we could talk about but I just want to
limit ourselves to these two concepts so
Oh a little bit more about briefly about
least cost avoider this is just a fun
fact there used to be a freight train
that would go down 11th Avenue in
Hatton daily carrying cows to the
meatpacking district where they would be
slaughtered this went on all the way up
into like the 40s or 50s actually which
is remarkable and Cowboys used to ride
into Manhattan to ride in front of the
train to warn people about the trains
you know impending arrival because 11th
Avenue for a while was known as the
Avenue of death and you know the the
circumstances here are a kind of radical
and complicated like they might be
actually in cryptocurrency networks we
have a lot of participants and it's hard
to note like there's obvious harm that
can happen but who's responsible who
should move you know you might say that
you know it just doesn't make sense to
have this train in Manhattan anymore but
it took them a long time to come to that
conclusion and to impose that cost a
regulatory tax if you will on the
railroad first they elevated it but then
it was still noisy and there's like cow
effluence falling from the elevated
track and then they then they said no
you should do this in Queens not
Manhattan and that's where the
slaughterhouses are today they're in
Queens and the elevated track is still
there and it's a lovely playground for
very rich people and tourists in in
Manhattan it's the High Line anyway so
yes so this this is what I was saying
earlier negative externalities mean
regulation might be necessary you can
find them maybe regulation is necessary
least cost avoid or principal if it's
applied well to the right people
maybe the regulation is just it's just a
folk theorem so let's talk now about two
of the most relevant categories of laws
that impact cryptocurrencies securities
laws and anti money laundering laws and
if you don't know anything about these
two it's okay because we're starting
from first principles here so what's the
negative externality that securities
laws seeks to address I think this is a
you know I just wrote this but it's
based on reading securities laws for a
long time and talking to policy makers
and looking at the the preamble of the
33 Act I think the heart of it is
there's this negative externality that
happens where we have malinvestment
which could mean all sorts of things
like society's resources are going to
the wrong products or purposes it could
mean you know people vulnerable people
are getting harmed because they're
losing their money so malinvestment is
occurring because of fraud
misrepresentation or a lack of effective
disclosure of relevant facts about the
investment by the issuer of a security
and this is fairly intuitive
it's intuitive in the cryptocurrency
space where mr. Mayweather decided to
promote you know sucks calm ICO and make
statements that might lead some people
to think this is a profitable
opportunity without any grounding for
that and without any registration or
disclaimers or other statements that the
sec says you should make to better share
information about the investment that
you're promoting before vulnerable
people potentially go out and look at
your Instagram and say I should buy that
negative externality it seems like you
know it's a buyer beware sort of thing I
view it Boras stock after you know see
his favorite I think that's right we can
think of so this gets into a sort of a
protectionist versus libertarian view of
negative externalities to try and stay
fairly neutral I'll just say that I
think negative externalities might
represent at least some form of market
failure and then the least cost avoider
might be the purchaser of the
unregistered security in which case
caveat emptor there is harm in the world
in inefficient markets but we're willing
to let the costs of those inefficiencies
be borne by ignorant people who
nonetheless despite probably knowing
better by these things
basically informational asymmetries
absolutely you're gonna buy their stuff
but you're not there oh yes and what
securities law tries to do is basically
have the company reports yes which I've
abstracted that is exactly what
securities law do and I've abstracted
that into a kind of tax on not reporting
which i think is a fair way of just
speaking more broadly about these things
because then we can speak also in the
same way about anti money laundering
laws just to build a more comprehensive
theory of so yeah what's the negative
externality that anti money laundering
laws seek to address well it's the ease
with which a criminal can hide the
profits of their crimes in the financial
system this is this is an interesting
negative externality I think it exists I
think there's there's definitely a case
where by providing a service just like
the factory is building widgets you
create some effect in society that's
undesirable like pollution and a bank by
providing banking services may knowingly
or not give shelter to flows of funds
that are essentially criminal or immoral
and that is a necessary fact of them
operating just like pollution is a
necessary fact of a factory operating
and so I think you can also think of
this one as a negative externality
produced by the productive activity of
running a bank and so I think this is
the ground truth of why we have both of
these laws if anyone disagrees feel free
to
so I would agree if money-laundering had
like strong scienter requirements
knowledge requirements and it doesn't
always if you are found operating an
unlicensed money transmission business
for example and you're not doing the KYC
AML that you were supposed to because
you never license doesn't matter if you
had any knowledge at all
of illegal money moving through your
institution the mere fact that you
didn't register and you didn't have a
program in place is something that you
can be found guilty of a federal felony
for a really serious federal felony so I
think in some cases money laundry is
obviously a crime in itself or at least
its accomplice liability for the crime
itself but in some cases what we charge
people people with is is is merely by
being part of the infrastructure you've
facilitated a problem and so we need you
to spend money even if you haven't done
anything wrong to stop that problem
banking facilitates money laundering
sure sure I'm just saying that within a
strict liability regime I have trouble
saying that the person who had no
knowledge that the money over there over
their systems was related to human
trafficking is themselves criminal
it may be regulatory deficient but I
don't think that's criminal unless
there's intent to to be an accomplice to
or to facilitate human trafficking and I
and this is something I do feel kind of
strongly about because we treat we treat
violations of anti money laundering as
if they're really in law we have malum
prohibitum and malum in SE and malum
prohibitum is you can't do this because
somebody in government said it's not
something to be done whereas malum in SE
is this idea that there are some things
that you can't do because they are truly
horrible murder is of malum in SE crime
whereas like parking on the wrong side
of the street is a malum prohibitum
prohibitum crime and I actually think
most money laundry though not all of it
might actually fall into more of a malum
prohibitum and certainly when people are
accused of simply not registering with
FinCEN and we have no evidence that
there was even money laundering it's
hard to say that that's not malum
prohibitum rather than mel would say so
oh yeah this this is fairly
self-explanatory with respect to the
negative externality of money laundering
from the excellent AMC show Breaking Bad
so who's the least-cost avoider of this
securities law negative externality well
the securities laws suggest and we can
either agree or disagree that it's the
issuer we could imagine others we were
just saying maybe it's the purchaser
who's the least cost of voyeur
we could even say maybe it's the
government we could have a system of
securities laws where the government
just focuses on investor education to
stop people from buying dumb crap and
they bear all the costs of that rather
than imposing costs on others we can
imagine lots of systems but securities
law says the issuer and the promoter so
adjacent people to the issuer who are
really Hawking this thing
since the Floyd Mayweather is not the
issuer of stocks calm but could be held
responsible and so in a in a nutshell
securities law boils down to this is
there a thing being sold as an
investment and is there a person upon
whom investors rely and if so the thing
is the security and the issuer or the
person upon whom investors rely needs to
register and do disclosures to correct
information asymmetries to make up for
this potential negative externality of
malinvestment and you can look at these
two questions as as interestingly kind
of also linked to our unnecessary versus
unjust if the thing is being sold as
investment and people expect profits
from it like they do with investments
then there's there's evidence here that
there could be malinvestment this might
be necessary and if there's a person
upon whom investors rely we can start to
find a least cost avoider maybe because
there's this one person there's a
singular person who if they shared more
information could really correct any of
the potential negative externalities
from malinvestment so the intuition here
is that we can't regulate everything as
securities because at a certain point
that wouldn't make sense so gold is sold
as an investment but if you're just
buying commodity gold there's no person
upon whom investors are relying for the
long-term value of their investment gold
goes up and down in price thanks to the
actions of thousands and thousands of
people in a free market or a generally
free market so you really you did meet
one there's definitely the possibility
of malinvestment and a negative
externality but we can't find a least
cost avoid or that makes any sense in
this context or maybe we could but we
just don't want to we need to draw a
line somewhere maybe all of the
potential people who could stop someone
from investing in gold are too many that
securities law style of disclosures to
address information asymmetry don't make
sense like as every gold miner gonna be
obligated to publish a prospectus about
how much gold they're gonna mine this
year that seems strange
and unnecessary this also does it rely
on the fact that there are many gold
vendors what if you change gold to the
diamonds and and there's like there's a
cartel so it's interesting I mean I've
never seen securities laws applied that
way but if you really had a strong
cartel that controlled the full supply
of a commodity and could manipulate it
and things like that it would start to
look like a good case for securities
regulation now that said we do have also
commodities regulation where if you can
manipulate the price of the thing we can
get you then so we'd probably get you
through commodities regulation rather
than saying you're a strong cartel that
could manipulate the price you need to
do disclosures we'd say you're a strong
cartel that can manipulate the price
we're going after you for manipulation
of a commodity rather than failing to
disclose facts about a commodity because
that doesn't make as much sense as
failing to disclose facts about a
security which is more like a share of
Apple stock is the paradigmatic security
where there's this guy Tim Cook who if
he doesn't speak honestly to the
investing public and speak completely ie
give them enough information then we can
obviously see why there would be a
chance for negative externalities
mispricing of Apple stock investment
booms bubbles things like that and they
could easily be addressed if we just got
him to say what he should say about the
number of shares and circulation about
the the the board of directors
composition of Apple and the other basic
disclosures that securities laws asked
for this is pretty high level so with
any particular asset we can engage in a
classification exercise why is the asset
desirable and what backs up the value so
if the asset is desirable for its use
then we have less chance of
malinvestment because people are just
treating this thing like something they
need and they're good maybe we'll
dispense of it quickly to perform some
function words if they're holding on to
it for a while obviously the chances of
malinvestment are real they have
expectations of future profits they they
could be harmed if
the things they believed about the thing
happened to be untrue and the value
plummets and then what backs up that
value the network in other words a large
number of people the entire gold
industry the entire number of people who
trade gold actively on several otherwise
unaffiliated exchanges or is it an
issuer who really backs up that value is
it like Tim Cook who makes most of the
command and control decisions at Apple
who's providing the value of an Apple
share and we've got intermediate cases
like the Liebherr Association which
decides what the value of the basket
that the Libra will represent Facebook's
new cryptocurrency just to give an
intermediate cryptocurrency example and
yet there's also a network of users and
the basket is composed of things that in
theory don't fluctuate much so how much
control do they have I guess would be
the operative question with Libra and so
we have these two axes I don't know if
you've seen this if you've ever seen me
present this before but I've been doing
this for a little while we can graph
these things in in two-dimensional space
which is fun maybe there are some things
where they're definitely treated as
investments and we really rely on the
issuers these our paradigmatic
securities like equities in shares and
publicly traded corporations for example
there are commodities that a lot of
people might use for scientific purposes
but also seek as investments maybe
because they're scarce like gold and the
value comes from no person in particular
but from a wide variety of persons
acting in an unaffiliated way there are
things that oil or real estate that we
might treat as an investment but
generally speaking we want to use them
and that's what markets in them are for
and you know their long-term value is
dependent on any number of things like
whether everyone starts using electric
cars whether people continue to want to
pay absurd prices to live in San
Francisco etc etcetera member run
worker-owned type cooperatives we could
put over here if you own a stake in the
in the profit making you know enterprise
that you are also running then it's
definitely an investment you have a
stake in your in your
business but it's you and your
compatriots who run it together you're
not looking to some single person who
isn't you and your compatriots to
provide the value of the investment it's
it's a network again and then down here
things that are useful and we rely on
the issuer and usually there's not
speculation about the value of these
things are things like loyalty points or
golf course memberships you could put
tickets to a show there and you could
put like this is a unique case from
securities law so there's there's case
law about all of these things and about
whether they're securities or not and
this is an interesting case where people
were sold warehouse receipts to barrels
full of whiskey and they were told by
the promoter you're just buying a barrel
of whiskey and here's your receipt you
can come pick up your multi-ton or like
half-ton barrel of giant barrel of
whiskey whenever you want but I'll hold
it for you and by the way if you let me
hold it for you for 15 years it's single
malt it'll be really good at that point
and I'll also probably help you find a
buyer at that point just give me the
money and I'll hold on to the you know
the barrel so at this point we can see
more of a rely on the issuer and the
thing isn't actually being used people
are just being told that this is a good
investment and yeah there's a whiskey
barrel in the warehouse so that kind of
just bought that but the SEC says yeah
we really think that that warehouse
receipt is basically a quasi share of
the whiskey distillery no one is
actually just buying whiskey they're
buying part of the stock literally of
the whiskey distillery their stock of
whiskey and so that was a security and
interestingly on the golf course
membership front Golf Course memberships
even if they're transferable are not
securities even though you do really
rely on the you know Trump to make the
golf course nice or not or whoever
maybe not Trump I wouldn't rely on Trump
he's got other things to do that's all I
mean you just can't run golf courses all
the time
but the SEC says no people buy these
memberships because they want a golf not
because they want an investment and yet
there are some cases where memberships
were pre-sold
which is a fun word in the
cryptocurrency space before the golf
course existed and he said it's gonna be
a really great golf course it's gonna be
huge it's gonna have 18 holes which all
golf courses do it'll be beautiful you
should pay me I'll give you a discount
on an early membership and then once
it's built you'll be able to play golf
that's the security according to the
relevant securities laws because it's
it's complete faith in the issuer to
actually deliver there's no way you can
golf today you're just waiting for them
to do what they said and build the thing
and they've sold a finite number of
memberships kind of like shares in their
future golf course so from a token
standpoint you pre-sale right so the
interesting thing is Kickstarter it
never came up
maybe because these things were small
enough amounts of money generally
speaking and this was sort of like well
let's let innovation bloom you could
have made a very credible argument in
the early days of Kickstarter these are
securities and the SEC could have come
for them to my knowledge they didn't I
actually haven't dug deeply into the
case law of like the bottom right there
yeah and sometimes they don't deliver
any product yeah totally agree and so
they are definitely on the edge I think
right now they're out but this is so
it's important to get a handle on how
legal reasoning works it's not it's not
mathematical as in proofs despite my
attempt to graph it it's fuzzy and so
yeah there are tokens that are exactly
like all of these things I would argue
and that's a huge huge fun fact like
there's tokens that could represent
equity there's tokens that could be a
claim to an object in a warehouse
and yet you're relying on the issuer and
you're never actually going to go pick
up the thing in the warehouse
there's tokens that are you know
promises of some future really nice
thing that you'll be able to access that
doesn't exist yet and there's tokens
that are promises of some really nice
thing that you can access today so maybe
the golf course that's pre-sold
memberships is a security or the ICO if
you will if the network's not running
and maybe the running Network is not a
security according to the same diversion
case law on golf courses for just just
to give one one potential avenue for
making these arguments I think there are
tokens that are kind of like digital oil
or fuel aetherium even uses this term
with respect to gas and I don't think
that's that's them just abusing it or
trying to look more like a commodity I
think it was a I don't even think they
knew about commodities or securities
laws when they chose the term gas it's
just what people do with ether among
other things in order to run smart
contracts there's plans for tokens that
will be like real estate where the
network will really just do distributed
file storage and you'll have some sort
of highly linked inbuilt currency so you
could kind of think of it as like
terabytes instead of square feet maybe
this might be a stretch feel free to
disagree yeah they're there they're more
complicated because they're non fungible
totally yeah yeah I I think the non
fungibility thing is a is a hiccup in
the analysis it might not be deadly at
all it's just a whole nother all of
these things like each unit is mostly
like the next I mean especially in the
token space like one eath is like 1/8
and that that actually helps provide
something called horizontal commonality
in the securities laws tests that say
that everybody's fates will rise and
fall together which is one of the
hallmarks of being a security and
there's even maybe like member run
cooperatives which might not be
securities because it really is member
run and and the SEC generally doesn't
treat the trading of shares in a closely
held in member run company as public
securities publicly traded securities
to be registered so if the Dow was
genuinely like actually decentralized
rather than having the curator as like a
choke point that people were relying
upon maybe it would have had a better
argument that it's not a security the
Dow token it was definitely a profit
you know oriented tokens with some
venture capital fund but the idea was it
was supposed to be member run and the
SEC said no it's not remember run
there's this curator this promoter and
there's the people that wrote the
software so we're still relying on an
issuer so this is the intuition behind
this whole thing
and at this point it should be obvious
the Securities Exchange Commission's
jurisdiction which is the broadest of
all securities regulators but other
security directors could expand their
jurisdiction might look something like
this
or it might look something like this
depending on how much they want to
stretch their interpretation of the
relevant law and whether a judge agrees
with them or it might look like this and
you know coin Center tries to generally
advocate for a more narrow
interpretation of securities laws but we
would definitely say that like if a if
pre-selling a golf course membership is
a security than pre-selling of a useful
token it's probably a security - I just
have trouble disagreeing with that
statement
how does the potential intangibility
ability of cryptocurrencies affect this
feel like the history of the currency
each coin really might not flinch
ability breaks down at that point I
think so
the sec concerns itself with the
economic realities of a transaction so
it wouldn't even be relevant to them
unless fungibility was breaking down so
much that some were worth more than
others the fact that in reality they're
all basically trading at the same I just
don't think it would actually be all
that relevant to their analysis
oh yeah there's no doubt that there are
things that could harm fungibility and
could lead some Bitcoin I mean Virgin
it's a terrible word virgin bitcoins
that come from a miner have never
touched any other transactions are
generally traded at a premium because
they're regarded either as collectible
that seems set a doubtful or as
assuredly clean from any past illegal
transactions is there ever a legal
distinction to a potential third axis
here which is whether you have some sort
of voting rights over the issuer like
you know third stock there's like common
stock voting stock so all of those would
be stock though that's the thing and
this is a map of when things are or or
endow are not securities and so if
things as I said really our member run
and there's no limited partners upon
whom the general of yeah limited
partners who are relying upon the
general partners if it's really member
run then it actually could fall out of
securities loss you're buying voting
shares are not like it is a proof of
state system different than you know
generally are some twenty token that
doesn't sort of project it could be in
dish' I mean there's also the Reeves
family resemblance test which is a
separate test from the Howey test which
this comes from and so maybe you could
make an argument that because this looks
like a typical debt liability and other
factors are associated with it there
there there are other tests but just
looking at the core of how the SEC has
treated these things it's always to the
Howey analysis which focuses primarily
on expectation of profits and reliance
on a third party and other indicia of
things that are typically like
securities like most securities have
voting rights it's not going to help you
but it it's not it's not prominent in
this test
and so I guess the point that I want to
make sticking Hobbs here is I kind of
think that stuff that is genuinely and I
don't mean to suggest that everything
that claims to be useful or a so-called
utility token is really here but if it
was really here and people really were
seeking it for its used value then a law
regulating it as the security is
unnecessary a la Hobbs is unnecessary
laws because we don't have the potential
for malinvestment because people aren't
actually holding this thing with the
expectation of profits that could be
disappointed from information
asymmetries and I think if you extended
securities laws too far in this
direction we're kind of in the unjust
territory it seems like yeah there are
investment expectations that can just be
disappointed like you could you could
you could buy gold and you could lose
your hat especially during the you know
the big bubbles around the gold
investment but is there a person we can
find in the gold industry that we could
just lease a is the low-cost avoider of
your bad choice to buy gold I don't
think so it should probably be you who's
responsible in this case this should
probably be a caveat emptor everything
so in the in the bottom case you said
more utility I mean who should be what
why isn't there any risk that the the
claimed utility doesn't doesn't exist
shares of Thera notes are and the
malinvestment around that was in large
part due to improper disclosures made by
theranos of like what their projected
revenue things like what that would be
but if you bought the blood testing
machine and it didn't work the way it
was supposed to that would be addressed
by other areas of law yeah either tore
it could be the effort the FDA it could
be the Federal Trade Commission saying
this is an unfair and deceptive product
and those are all also applicable to
cryptocurrency so when I when I exclude
them from one area of law I'm not being
an anarchist who says they shouldn't be
regulated at all I'm just
talking now about securities laws I do
think the FTC is a would be a valuable
regulator of so-called useful tokens so
one of the dirty tricks I kind of seen
icos who pretended to be utility
Tompkins is that they would say you know
our token would later let you buy you
know something of the shared rights yep
what the exchange rate you know one
token one ride would have nailed down
the value and you know the buyer then
knows pretty much what he's buying yeah
just letting this thing float is the
thing that make bubbles possible and me
so how do you how would you would you
know put that into this framework do you
have any so I suppose letting it float
makes it a bit more like gambling like
you're buying it and you're not
immediately going to convert it into the
useful service you're gonna hope that
you're gonna get a lot more useful
service than people currently expect and
so that goes into that you know maybe
people are suddenly buying it for
investment purposes not for its
usefulness but that said I think it
should like there's there's interesting
economic benefits to building a system
that doesn't that that pre sells things
or sells things at a price that can
adjust and as far as the number of goods
you get in the future for you know
shifts and so okay I'll wrap it up soon
aunty money laundering laws these cost
avoider choke points in the financial
system what do I mean this is from
Treasury the term money transmission
services means the acceptance of
currency funds or other value that
substitutes for currency from one person
and the transmission of currency funds
or other value that substitutes for
currency to another location or person
by any means you are a chokepoint
a wants to pay B and you are in the
middle you accept from a and transmit to
B or a wants to move from location A to
B
you facilitate that by at least
transiently achieving custody over the
thing and with respect to cryptocurrency
this with respect to all the financial
system this makes sense
a necessary link in the in the movement
of money is definitely the least cost
avoider to illegal money flowing through
that channel assuming that we're ready
to address that negative externality now
maybe we just don't like the idea of
financial surveillance at all and we
don't want to address the negative
externality but I think this makes sense
for at least cost avoider and with
respect to crypto currencies FinCEN in
May 2019 says the determining factor if
your that lease cost a void or if you're
that obligated entity is whether the
person acting as an intermediary has
total and independent control over the
value and so they're really talking
about say a coin base who holds your
cryptocurrency for you or a Bank of
America which has your bank balance for
you they're not talking about at least
not yet and this could all change of
course they're not talking about say a
miner who's one of several paths through
a network that your transaction could
end up clearing through these are
essential paths these are paths that
actually could misdirect or move or
completely fail to transact on your
behalf and then you're out of luck
necessary intermediaries who have actual
independent control over the value and I
think this makes sense now
just like we came to the question who's
the least cost avoider in a bad
investment in gold can we impose that
obligation on every gold miner in the
world that seems wrong it should
probably be the person we come to the
question of if we wanted to find a new
lease cost avoider for a world without
choke points because suddenly people
aren't transmitting through Bank of
America all the time but instead
transmitting through the etherium
Network can we rightly say that every
node on the etherium network is the
least cost avoider to stop money
laundering and therefore needs to
automatically report the transaction
information on the etherium network
including the identities of the
participants without a warrant from a
judge for the search and seizure of that
information that is radically different
I don't think this is least cost avoider
and I don't think this is kind
the two tional either which was my
stretch topic for today so yeah fails on
st. Augustine I'd say to make every node
or maybe even every minor depending on
how be central as the system is a money
services business who needs to basically
survey all the users of the network and
so far regulators have generally agreed
with the approach I've described today
you can check out more at this link with
respect to CFTC policy on authors of
software and whether they be liable and
you can check out these two links if
you're interested in the anti-money
laundering stuff which has now been
exported through fat.if to the rest of
the world so this is actually not a
parochial u.s. concern this is global
and we don't have time for our stretch
topic but I'm happy to give that
presentation to anyone who's interested
[Applause]
thoughts on whether certain regulation
should apply or should not you know in a
principled way coming from so much more
rudimentary first principles yeah yeah
so how much regulators like use this gun
who's to like the Royal at least
consistent implications the regulation
or are they three and more body so I
think mostly regulators are driven by a
faithful interpretation of the existing
statutory law and their own previously
promulgated regulations and then you
have to ask yourself whether those were
promulgated wisely and most of those in
fact all of those with respect to
securities laws anti-money laundering
laws were promulgated or passed into law
by Congress before crypto currencies
existed and there's something that I
think is really interesting there I
think they were actually pretty wise in
maybe a tacit knowledge kind of sense I
think a lot of the first principles
calculus that I'm explaining goes into
lawmaking when it's done well and I'm
usually sometimes have a lack of faith
in the wisdom of policy like the state
money transmission licensing framework
but learning more about securities laws
and anti money laundering laws by being
a coin Center for five years I actually
have much more respect for those laws
and I think they're actually
surprisingly well calibrated which is
something that unfortunately some
blockchain advocates will tell you like
ah securities laws don't let me raise
money I'm like well maybe you shouldn't
maybe you should just build good tech
and raise money from like andreessen
horowitz like a normal person right and
so this would be a rebuttal to them this
would say these laws address kind of
timeless problems that all go all the
way back to st. Augustine and Thomas
Hobbes
negative externalities as far as I know
which transaction made structure assume
a lot of energy negative externalities
and because it I mean people talk about
building you know carbon credits and
things like that that would be fairly
directly a type of pigouvian tax one
that would be transferable which makes
it a little bit more like cool 20th
century than 18th century but if it
applied to regular industries then it
should apply to a Bitcoin I'd say that
said I think actually a lot of Bitcoin
mining and I'm just saying this off the
cuff we have a research paper that just
says that the existing estimates aren't
great and and and says like here the
problem with their analysis I don't have
a research paper that says anything
conclusively because it's very hard to
get empirical data but anecdotally we
hear that lots of Bitcoin miners are
actually in places with cheap
hydroelectric power geothermal power and
if you think about it a Bitcoin miner
can be located anywhere in the world
they don't have to be a shipping port
because they're only inputs and outputs
are internet and electricity so they can
go to places in the world where
electricity is cheap because nobody
lives there and there seems to be a lot
of sunlight or a lot of geothermal or a
lot of water up high that will come down
and so it might not be the case that you
find that all Bitcoin mining is
generating this pollution issue and they
might be the early adopters of green
energy is is one pet theory of mine but
that needs empirical evidence
so you were about to maybe conclude with
privacy law and I was just gonna say
that there's another negative
externality yes things all are all of
our lives and they're a one of the
negative externalities like soot from
factories is the little bits of
information that's about us that are
everywhere and maybe bitcoin is actually
good at you know
when other cryptocurrencies is avoiding
these I think that's absolutely right
yeah yeah it societies just waking up to
that and I think I think there's
actually a case to be made that the Bank
Secrecy Act which is the model for
international AML regimes as well when
applied in certain ways that it is
currently applied even to regular
financial institutions might be
unconstitutional and you know there was
a court case that that said that the
Bank Secrecy Act is constitutional in
the 1970s when it was first promulgated
back in 1970s how many transactions
would you ask your bank to make on your
behalf per week one - and then you make
all your transactions in cash now they
see every transaction you make with your
cards or online
it's a mountain more data and the laws
have changed such that they need to
automatically report suspicious activity
reports and they file millions of these
every year this is all changed since the
court case that held that the Bank
Secrecy Act was constitutional if you
think of the Constitution is like a
another metal law to ensure some degree
of like we only want necessary laws and
just laws maybe maybe we're just waiting
for that day of reckoning with respect
to American values or liberal values and
mass surveillance warrantless
surveillance which is what the Bank
Secrecy is today rather than maybe when
it person that's the second talking the
f8 gives beings they have an open day
yeah speakers from industry and what
struck me is that everybody was talking
about big data data pools data links you
know more let's bring everyone's Neal
you have an international body you know
with for 40 or so countries talking
about joining datas and talking about
look looking for terrorist networks and
connecting the dots and and I was
appalled right and I was the only one in
the room but pretty much looking at them
you know with horror yeah so I don't
think we're in for a bumpy road in that
in that sense let's thank the speaker
and take the discussion to the break
will start at 10:50